wthr.com in indianapolis all right we
were looking at the headlines with
Andrew Luck from a year ago and they're
applicable to now it almost feels like
there's more doubt now than there was a
year ago Bob at this time that right
well no I I wouldn't say that I think
they feel pretty pretty good about where
he's at first of all he's you know if
you looked at some pictures from about a
year ago he was so skinny he looked like
he had just whipped up a batch of
moonshine and it's still I mean he he
had looked crazy awful and now the guy
is absolutely yoked I mean he showed up
at the Indy 500 and a muscle shirt and
he was bigger than any of us could
remember the big thing is that Chris
Ballard the GM is the one guy who's
always sounded the note of you know he's
been careful about what he's been saying
about Andrew Luck and now even he has
come out and said yes Andrew will start
throwing on August 1st the first day of
training camp here in Indianapolis so
there doesn't seem to be anything
standing in his way you know in theory
but we've heard that before yeah I saw
the pictures of him he looked like he
was a linebacker but you know can he
play linebacker if it doesn't work out a
quarterback bomb well yeah he probably
could be a safety yeah I think so but
you know I mean this is this is the
make-or-break year I mean you can't get
healthy then they've got to look you
know forward and and start thinking
about drafting a quarterback or signing
a a veteran quarterback but was there
any talk of taking a quarterback if they
stayed at 3 was there any talk of a
quarterback selection there at all
absolutely none and the fact that they
went that they moved back in the draft
and were so enthusiastic about going out
and and strengthening their offensive
line tells me that they believe fully
that he's going to be back and you know
I'm not sure what's stopping him from
throwing this week at minicamp
it seems to me would be a good time but
you know Andrew himself has said that he
tried to come back too fast the last
time he skipped some steps so I think
they're just being really maybe overly
careful this time around making sure
they go through the whole process and
have him ready by August 1st Coby Bruce
Ed's gonna he's going to still be the
backup quarterback yes absolutely there
was there was some interest expressed to
chris ballard about training him and I
think if Andrew comes back and he's
healthy and he can stay healthy for an
extended period of time I think that's
something that they would think about
they would entertain but for now Jacoby
Burr said is a really good insurance
policy you know he played reasonably
well last year knew but that was coming
in that was coming in cold
he came here after the first week of the
season didn't really understand the
offense and now he's got an entire
offseason with the new coaching staff to
get all the reps and learn the new
offense so I think he'll be they'll be a
fine as a backup but like you know
you're not gonna win a lot of games with
him Bob great stuff as always we
appreciate it we'll check in with you
later on this summer sounds good take
care guys that's Bob Kravitz columnist
wthr.com for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]